there's a big question at the center of
life in our democracies today how do we
fight terror without destroying
democracies without trampling human
rights I've spent much of my career
working with journalists with bloggers
with activists with Human Rights
researchers all around the world and
I've come to the conclusion that if our
democratic societies do not double down
on protecting and defending human rights
freedom of the press and a free and open
Internet radical extremist ideologies
are much more likely to persist okay all
done
thank you very much no just joking I
actually want to drill down on this a
little bit so one of the countries that
has been on the front lines of this
issue is Tunisia which was the only
country to come out of the Arab Spring
with a successful democratic revolution
five years later they're struggling with
Syria's terror attacks and rampant Isis
recruitment and many Tunisians are
calling on their government to do
whatever it takes to keep them safe
tunisian cartoonist Nadya kerry has
summed up the situation with this
character who says i don't give a damn
about human rights i don't give a damn
about the revolution i don't give a damn
about democracy and liberty i just want
to be safe satisfy asked his jailor
you're safe now if the tunisian people
can figure out how to deal with their
terrorism problem without ending up in
this place it will be a model not only
for their region but for all of us
the reality is that civil society
journalists and activists are coming
under attack
from extremists groups on the one hand
and in many countries also from their
own governments we're seeing bloggers
and journalists being jailed charged and
intimidated by their own governments
many of which are allies with the West
in the war on terror just three examples
a friend and former colleague of mine
Hashana Al Murat has been charged with
threatening state security along with
six other activists in Morocco the Saudi
blogger Raef Badawi has been jailed and
flogged for insulting Islam and
criticizing the Saudi regime on his blog
more recently the Turkish representative
for reporters without borders
Erol under ulu has been detained and
charged with spreading terrorist
propaganda because he and some other
activists have been supporting Kurdish
media anti-terror measures quickly turn
into state repression without strong
protection from minority communities and
for peaceful debate this needs to be
supported by a robust independent local
media but while that's not really
happening Washington is teaming up with
Silicon Valley and with Hollywood to
pour millions hundreds of millions of
dollars into what's called counter
messaging a fancy word for propaganda to
counter the terrorist propaganda
spreading all over the internet in
Europe internet referral units are being
set up so that people can report on
extremist content that they find and get
it censored the problem is that all of
this propaganda monitoring and
censorship completely fails to make up
for the fact that the people who are the
most credible voices who can present
credible ideas and alternative solutions
to real economic social and political
problems in their community that are
causing people to turn to to turn to
extremism in the first place are being
silenced by their own governments this
is all adding up to a decrease in
freedom across the world freedom house
the human rights organization reports
that 2015 marks the 10th straight year
in a row of decline in freedom worldwide
and this is not just because of the
actions of authoritarian governments
it's also because democratic governments
are increasingly cracking down on
dissenters whistleblowers and
investigative journalists un
secretary-general ban ki-moon has warned
that preventing extremism and promoting
him rights go hand in hand it's not to
say that governments shouldn't keep us
safe of course they should but we need
public oversight transparency and
accountability to the rule of law
meanwhile extremists are literally
killing off civil society in some
countries since 2013 in Bangladesh over
a dozen secular bloggers and community
activists have been literally
slaughtered by extremists while the
government has done very little from the
city of Raqqa in Syria
people like Rukia Hassan naji jerf have
been assassinated for their reporting
out of Isis controlled territory the
citizen media group called Raqqa is
being slaughtered silently relies on
strong encryption to send out their
reports and shield themselves from
interception and surveillance yet
authorities and countries like the
United States the United Kingdom and
many other democracies are seeking to
use the law to either weaken or outright
ban strong encryption because the bad
guys are using it too we have got to
fight for the right of citizens to use
strong encryption otherwise dissent and
investigative journalism is going to
become even more difficult in even more
places and the bad guys the criminals
and terrorists are still going to find
ways to communicate kudos to the
companies that are standing up
for their users right to use encryption
but when it comes to censorship the
picture is much more troubling yes
there's a real problem of extremist
content start spreading all over the
internet and Facebook YouTube and
Twitter are among the many companies who
report having taken down hundreds of
thousands of pieces of content and
deactivating accounts that are connected
to the extremists speech the problem is
their enforcement mechanisms are a
complete black box and there is
collateral damage take for example I had
al Baghdadi an activist who makes fun of
Isis on Twitter had his account
deactivated because he shares a surname
with a prominent Isis leader last
December a number of women named Isis
which also happens to be the name of an
Egyptian goddess had their accounts
deactivated and this woman who lives in
the United States and is a computer
programmer reported on Twitter about her
deactivation on Facebook managed to get
enough media attention to have her
account reinstated but that's the thing
she had to get media attention and
journalists aren't immune David Thompson
an expert on terrorism and reporter for
Radio France international had reports
deleted from his Facebook account
and had his account deactivated for
several days because they contained
pictures of Isis flags even though he
was just reporting on Isis not promoting
it and then we have stories from people
like this Egyptian man Hamid Abdullah he
who reported recently in a event in
Washington DC that some of his arguments
with extremists he now spends his time
on social media arguing with Isis
followers trying to get to turn them
away and some of his arguments with
these extremists get deleted which he
believes has the effect of shielding
them from alternative points of view
it's unclear whether Facebook even knows
the extent of the collateral damage or
the other companies as well but we do
know that journalism activism and public
debate are
being silenced in the effort to stamp
out his extremist speech so with these
companies having so much power over the
public discourse they need to be held
accountable they need to hold carry out
impact assessment to identify and fix
the problems that we're clearly seeing
they need to be more transparent about
their enforcement mechanisms and they
need to have clear appeal and grievance
mechanisms so people can get their
content reinstated now I've been talking
for the last ten minutes about how
governments and companies are making it
more difficult for people like these
this is a picture of members of the
citizen media Network Global Voices that
I helped to co-found over ten years ago
with my friend Ethan Zuckerman
interestingly about five years ago right
after the Arab Spring the data scientist
Gilad lotin created a network map of the
people in global voices who were heavy
users of Twitter during the Arab Spring
and he found that many of these people
served as key information nodes between
activists and journalists throughout the
Tunisian and Egyptian revolution we've
got to make sure that these people not
only survive but are able to continue to
thrive many of them are still active
other than the ones that have gone to
jail or have been driven into hiding or
exile all around the world people who
are sick and tired of fear and
oppression are linking up in their
communities and across borders we've got
to do everything we can to push our
governments and companies to do a better
job of protecting their rights we've
also got to be more mindful about how
our own personal political consumer and
business choices affect people like
these around the world
also if you follow the news it's pretty
clear that that alone isn't going to be
enough we've got to take personal
responsibility by joining or at very
least actively supporting the growing
ecosystem of individuals and groups who
are fighting for social justice
environmental sustained
ability Government Accountability Human
Rights freedom of the press and a free
and open Internet all around the world
I believe that ultimately we can
overcome the digitally empowered
networks of extremism demagoguery and
hate but we've got to do this by really
beefing up the global networks of
citizens around the world powered by
people who are working hard every day
and taking personal risk for a future
world that is more peaceful just open
and free thanks very much for listening